I'm a theorist we write down our
equations you know in that equation this
is the equation that come to life this
is what this is what I look like this
this is an equation come to life this is
not just you know a bit of
differentiation a few Greek symbols this
is those equations in reality this could
be this could reveal extra dimensions
this could reveal supersymmetry this
could reveal you know the origin of dark
matter
you know this machine it's not just an
equation I've written down on a piece of
paper anywhere this is this is it this
is really looking for stuff this is
incredible
we were just about to go into Atlas and
but just before we go and we can see
that this this big mural on the outside
I quite like it actually I think it's
pretty good I think it's there yeah it's
not of it because he still just say no I
know because we were talking about it
yesterday Radian I said I thought it was
there
I quite like they didn't like the other
thing of interest that we can see it in
the back row you see those big tubes
they contain helium and that's the
helium that gets used to cool down the
the superconductors in it and then the
magnets yeah so this is this is the main
control room here at Atlas normally to
be very busy but of course we're on
shutdown at the moment but one of the
informed people that's still here is
that it's that lady over there with the
green cardigan who's the the safety
person so she's making sure that nothing
goes belly-up while we're down there and
also so she's faced with the most
important person here
and again
we had classics
let's see off is a Steve yeah I could
have these crazy mud
that
enormous
it really is enormous is incredible the
scale of it is just what what hits your
first time I mean it really is huge
ivy nuts that you meet use across
apparently about don't think that does
it justice you know when you're actually
here and you can see how truly bigger is
its vast you know and its kind of think
it's crazy to think that you know it's
so big and yeah we're looking at
something so small it's paradox of the
whole thing but you because you need
that a typical collision produces many
hundreds of particles and each component
of the Atlas detector is necessary to
build a full picture of the collision
this is where the collisions are taking
place on one of the places where the
collisions are taking place along the
LHC and you'll you'll see up here if I
just look at that blue bit that will
that blue in case minis that's where the
beam is the protons are coming in from
this side and then they meet protons
coming from the other side and they
collide right in the middle of that that
big detector so that's where all the
stuff's going on inside there so the bit
that we see here is called the de muon
spectrometer to actually see what's
going on inside the detector we'd have
to move this out we'd literally have to
pull this out and they do do that I'll
just be probably do do that then you've
got sort of some magnets behind that and
then you literally have to pull another
wheel out and then you've got access to
all the color colour images for example
the electromagnetic calorimeter the
Hadron character limiter and within that
you've got the the inner detector and
the pipe itself so literally it is deep
within that is where all where it's all
going on where it's all kicking off well
no this is this is where a lot of the
informations you know what we learn
about a lot of the information in
precisely this part this is where the
muons the muons are a common through
this is we then an awful lot from the
well the muons are doing in particularly
if you look at these sorts of these
triggers here this is all the you know
there's sort of copper colored parts
those are the triggers you know they can
detect the position of these muons down
to you know the timing of the muon
passing by down to it
of a nanosecond so these are all these
remarkably accurately telling us where
and when these muons are passing through
as a muon passes through these tubes it
leaves a trail of electrically charged
ions and electrons which drift to the
sides and center of the tube what's what
special is is how the muons behaving if
the muon you know has it perhaps lost a
little bit but a little bit less energy
than you might have thought and all the
energies don't add up and then you know
you've got a lot of these muons you've
got a lot of these different events
going on you add up the energies and say
let's say you've got some missing
anything well
that would tell you something I would
tell you that maybe with that energy
gone maybe the energies escaped into an
extra dimension maybe you've produced
there a dark matter particle there's
various things that that could mean and
that's a so you learn an awful lot just
by having a polyfill bits so actually
the Higgs event that was that we think
may have happened just before Christmas
that actually that would have not got
out this far okay because what that was
was it higgs decaying into into two
photons those photons would have been
absorbed by the electromagnetic
calorimeter which is right in the center
of all I'd say it's the first color
imitator outside the inner detector so
you know they would have been absorbed
at that stage they would have been given
a little glow you know and essentially
they would've been spotted at at that
point so they would have been you know
they would have been stopped coming out
but it's not the stuff that we would
have been interested in
Heath's event can be detected deep
within why do you need this new on
detector all the way out here because
you need knowledge of the entire event
of everything that's going on I mean you
know in any in any one collision
you know this there's an awful lot of
stuff happening right so you've got okay
you will have muons flying out well
that's not the stuff you're interested
in you have to know the full picture to
know what's going on deep inside that's
the important thing
so we're in a really noisy bit now as
you can probably tell and I would say to
shout cause that thing's making a racket
you know it really makes you feel like
you're really in the heart of this
machine now I mean of course where it
stood now you wouldn't be able to stand
when this thing's on too much radiation
flying around too many particles that
could see this you know some serious
damage so obviously on apparently these
walls are seven meters thick so you know
this is really old
well encased let's talk about the you
know the pipe itself and what's going on
in there
you're basically got protons whizzing
around at nearly the speed of light you
know they're doing that circuit of the
of the end of the kind at eleven
thousand times a second you know and
they'd certainly they do that for about
half the day and in that time they would
have traveled almost to the sort of
distance of Neptune so I mean this you
know they really go there any vomiting
I'm making it they don't they're only
carrying each one it's only carrying the
energy of a mosquito in flight which
doesn't sound that impressive so you
know the building all this so this great
big cairn yeah we're we're making these
these protons of giving them the energy
of a mosquito well I guess that might
not sound impressive but you think about
how small the the proton is right that's
what's interesting I mean if I if I clap
my hands right there's more energy in
that collision than in any given
collision up there okay but of course
it's a occurring over a much larger
region of space now just to see how that
makes a difference when you shrink
things down you know if I had a needle
attached to there and I would think
twice about hitting that so hard so that
sort of emphasizes the point it you know
squeezing things down makes a real
difference in it I mean this beam it's
coming around it's about a centimeter
thick right and then when it could when
you get to this point where it's gonna
it's gonna hit the chamber it's gonna
it's it's basically gonna collide they
need to squeeze that beam right right
down right right down down to a hair's
breadth and then you get this collision
okay now you've got in each bunch you've
got about 10 to the 11 protons okay and
yeah in any given collision event only
about 20 of those actually
collide worthless the rest of them well
they just carry on
no worries they just carry on obviously
that's the vast majority right do you
think in fact this is one of the
remarkable things you've got these each
collision 10 to the 11 protons 20 of
them actually involved in it in a
natural event and then of those events
most of them are thrown away as a stair
you know we talk about a billion events
for second there any interesting that we
only keep data of our hundred of those
okay because most of our stuff we know
about stuff we're not that interested in
so literally 20 out of 10 to the 11
actually do something interesting and
then out of those we've been off the
vast majority as well so actually the
ones they actually get to give you say a
Higgs event it's sort of you know
literally it's like within the lottery
that's so unlikely what happens to the
other protons after the ones that miss
out on the collision well they go round
again and they go round again and we go
around again and of course most of the
protons will never get the chance to be
evolved and it will never be involved in
a collision most of what people but I
don't eventually up about half a day
they decide to dump the beam and they
basically just get goats are beamed off
and they just smash the beam into you
know essentially a wall and they just
don't power the energy well then this
they just they they generate some new
few protons and start a whole procedure
again those want to gone they've done it
don't work they missed a chance
so we've just we've just taken the
elevator up from from the basically the
ground floor of the the detect their up
to this high a bit so you can actually
looking down on the on the beam pipe now
and we're top of the detector and they
told us as well it's actually an
elevator which drops right into the
center of this thing as well
it's not the only elevator we haven't
been in that one we've been in the in
this service one they're a bit reviews
if any of these keys are missing the LHC
cannot switch on all right so it's a
safety Pig essentially so if I take this
back to but to Nottingham with me the
LHC II is not going on so important I
put this back on that other way out so
said I'm also quite reassuring that I've
got it in my hand because that thing
ain't got a switch arm while I've got
this in my hand so that's good it's this
is it it's the detector we're here
and you got the theme comes in and it
goes into this monster it's noisy it's
it's light if you've been on a on a ship
on them you know across across the
English Channel or something and you're
on you're on the the home of the engines
constantly that's what you can hear on
you and you can just see people I mean
you just get an idea of the size of it
there are two people here and this it's